صباح يوم ال 17 من ديسمبر قرار واحد خرج
من اجتماع بوتين مع قياده الاركان حرب
شامله قد تنفذوا في اي لحظه وهكذا يروي
اندرياس القصه
محاصره الجيش الاوكراني لا تزال الهدف رغم
الفشل سابقا بسبب قله عدد القوات لم
تتجاوز 120,000 والذلك كانت اولى الخطوات
مضاعفه العدد ثلاث مرات لكن هذه المره من
اجل محاصره كامله لاوكرانيا من حدودها مع
اوروبا عينها النخبه الجيش
بقيادته
تهدف الاستدراك اوكرانيا الى محمود
وسوليدار تنفيذ الخطه بدافع فعليه منذ
ايام جامعه اخرى هي اودس عبره سالم بحريه
غرب المدينه اختيار المنطقه يعود يضعف
الدبابات وعبرها يتم التقدم نحو مندوبا من
اجل قلب النظام ثم تعيين حكومه موليه تمنع
المساعدات القادمه من رومانيا عبر اراضيها
حرب هجينه اخرى تترجم نظريات دراسه هنا
والهجوم من بيلاروسيا جبههن جديده المشرف
عليها اوليج سيليكونوف خمير بشئ اوكرانيا
وخدما للسنوات
غرب اوكرانيا السيطره على ضواحيها تكفيين
لتقطع الامدادات والمدينه هي مفتاح النقل
بالسكه الحديديه بقطعيها تعزل اوكرانيا عن
بولندا
الاخيره تنطلقوا من محور الزبالهوجيا نحو
العمق الاوكراني والقائد هنا اليكسيكن
العوده لكيف قد تكون فقط بهدف اوكرانيا
فالعاصمه لم تعد هدفا قطعوا الدعم الغربي